I want to get my hands on that phone
there's one thing you guys need to know
about me I hate boxes they're always
blocking the cool stuff I got to get rid
of them which is why I hate this box
it's blocking the new Sega's v-squared
phone and I want to take a look I'm drew
Coolidge and we have the phone that's
decided you know what let's jump
lightyears ahead with our features and
make this one giant leap for phone kind
stick around I'm going to unbox the hell
out of this B squared this is hashtag
news now for normal hashtag news
episodes I'm always standing around like
a sucker but this is an unboxing episode
which means I get to sit down get ready
ah ah
all right we're unboxing now this is
scheduled to be released in the fall of
2015 you know the same time Doc Brown
and Marty McFly should be playing around
with hoverboards and self trying jackets
your jacket is no dry so basically this
is as cool as offer board don't build it
up I'm filling it up it's as cool as a
hoverboard this phone actually does have
a lot of height you know other companies
are making like the small change it's
like oh here's a few megabytes extra
each time people would say guess they're
like why don't we just go to the best
possible phone we can make that's what
this is
they made a campaign on IndieGoGo to
raise a million dollars and in less than
two days it was fully funded the thing
I'm most excited about is that this will
come with 464 gigs of storage space
I didn't misspeak like I normally do it
comes with 64 gigs standard and then you
can combine that with two 200 gig
microSD cards that's nearly half a
terabyte of storage that's more storage
space than your mom's attic but not her
basement
but is the her booty so this whole week
we've been partnering up with saygus and
one of the cool perks is they don't gave
us this phone to check out before it's
available to anybody else they didn't
give it to us that we have to give it
back no it's mine now
great thing about the box it to be it's
a v-neck so let's get into it the grand
unveiling
obviously we'll get back to this first
the box what's underneath I'm like a cat
who decides I'm not gonna use that
expensive toy you just bought me I'm
gonna just live in this box alright
first thing we have a reversible USB
cord and this is cool there's not a lot
of reversible cords on the market right
now in fact Apple had to do a whole
redesign to make their cords reversible
at all on top of that it's a USB 3.0
which means superfast transfers to the
phone so this is where the magic happens
this is the phone now this phone is
super durable even without a case
there's a Kevlar frame all around the
outside that's friggin Kevlar I can stop
bullets you just activated a disclaimer
what I saw may may not be able stop
bullets didn't try to help you get up
come up without wit play down feel super
light this is lighter than the phone I
currently have in my pocket I won't tell
you what brand that is cuz you don't
have a phone in your line I use a rotary
phone and in its most star trek-like
move yet there's a biometric fingerprint
scanner see it's right there where my
thumb already wants to be hey buddy
you're home that's your own little
biometric scanner not making friends I'm
talking to my phone you're friends with
you you gotta be friends with all of
your appendages
now this has two great cameras the
rear-facing one is 21 megapixels with
optical image stabilization I got you
yeah all right and the front-facing ones
13 megapixels so you can take all the
selfies but back to the rear-facing
camera once again this can also take 4k
video full 1080 V P sorry I'm always
trying to think about V and not P
another thing proving that saygus is
actually listening to what we want this
phone is fully waterproof it's an ipx7
waterproofing means it can be in a meter
of water for up to 30 minutes but if you
can't fish your phone out of the toilet
in 30 minutes like who can't get their
phone out of the toilet after 30 that's
30 minutes to find someone else pay them
10 bucks to reaching your toilet and
grab your phone I know a guy he'll do it
for cheap I'm just poor what's crazy is
it still fully waterproof even with a
removable battery boom this is a
removable 3100 milliamp hours battery
C fully removable even with my little
child fingers you're not supposed to
take that out oh wait no yeah you can as
you can see there's also two micro SD
slots which can add up to 400 gigs of
storage
that's insane on the back you can see
here this has a fractal antenna this
isn't just a design this means something
not like your shirt my shirt means
plenty most antennas can only take one
small range of frequencies but with a
fractal antenna it can accept multiple
frequencies this adds like a full bar of
service I don't know why more phones
don't have this all phone should have
this why you holding out on bars here
you can see the built-in stereo speakers
it comes with Harman Kardon sound
technology which is nicer than the
speakers in my car if I had one notice
how they're on the front aimed at your
face so when you watch something the
sound is going to you why doesn't every
phone do this these Harman Kardon
speakers are what they call 3d audio
because it actually comes from the
receiver and the speakers it's like a
little movie theater
this also has noise canceling cipher
sound technology meaning when you're
talking to someone it will help cut out
all the surrounding sounds except for
that person's voice right here you can
see the transmitter that allows the
phone to connect wirelessly lag free to
any monitor or TV you can play a game on
your phone and what is on your phone is
on the screen with zero lag so I guess
if you have a business job you can make
a presentation and then beam it straight
a business job business job I don't know
I don't even own a suit nope or you can
use this camera to shoot the 4k video
and then beam it straight to your HDTV
you'll be like hey mom look what I just
recorded today no no not that one the
other one mom this is a 5 inch full HD
display as you can see the screen is
edge to edge so there's no wasted space
and you can actually look at the screen
in direct sunlight so like I said before
it's pretty lights about 5 ounces it's
about the weight of like the first thing
I popped in my head is it weighs about
as much as like three peanuts but like
full peanuts and shells
that's the first thing my brain went to
was like how heavy is this 3 peanuts
this also has a button for the camera
not like other phones but you're trying
to get rid of everybody some buttons we
like this is a button we like if you're
interested in all the nerdy specs and
stuff here you go and nerdy done great
an IR transmitter meaning it can be a
real remote control replacement can't
figure out where they're all hiding but
there's three microphones in here I
think in there I'm thinking there and
they're there are you comforting it bad
they're there they're there it'll be
fine it's that a motion sensor it
doesn't have one of those
I'm turning it on whoo right now we have
tons of giant lights aimed at this you
can still see it perfectly clear this
isn't the software it'll eventually
deliver with but you can take a quick
look so let me just take a quick selfie
with the 13 megapixel front facing
camera no drew you don't want to see it
at 13 megapixels don't they look like
don't just put vaseline on the lens sure
if you guys found this video helpful or
entertaining go ahead and hit like this
phone is really awesome if you want to
support them or pre-order the phone the
link is right here we'll also put it in
the description here at hashtag news
we're always bringing you the latest and
entertainment and technology news so if
you guys want to be up-to-date hit
subscribe and follow along with us go
ahead and comment with which feature
you're most excited about
there there there then stop comforting
idea it's the emotion sensor it can tell
it's a fingerprint scanner seriously
this is amazing go to the indiegogo
pre-order let's do it click click click
click alright you've clicked I'm drew
Coolidge and I'm never leaving this
chair go never leaving nope nope ok no
you're not